[Musique]
envies de lecture avec françois david
bonjour bonjour vous êtes l'auteur d'un
livre qui savaient le pacte de
corruption qui tint un thriller
politico-financier ce qui est un grand
un genre assez rare en france info va
oui c'est surtout anglo saxons était que
c'est vrai on va en parler
en un mot je vous présente vous êtes
vous êtes un haut fonctionnaire vous
avez été un haut fonctionnaire vous êtes
ancien élève de l'ena promotion jean
jaurès qui a donné d'autres écrivains ya
pas que vous il ya une certaine
françoise chandernagor et regarde la maj
la major de la promotion un jour nous
positionner bonne écrivain c'est
absolument
et on va reparler d'ailleurs de dena
tout à fait ce qu'il n'est pas mal
question dans ce dans ses livres vous
avez été directeur de l'adt re d'adressé
la direction des relations économiques
extérieures c'est à dire du commerce
extérieur de la france on parlera aussi
de commerce extérieur parler aussi pour
pour ce livre vous avez dirigé la coface
aussi alors la coface et la société
d'assurance qui assurent le le risque
d'insolvabilité des entreprises
exportatrices avait aussi dirigé des
cabinets ministériels
vous avez un parcours évidemment qu'il
vous fait que vous connaissez très bien
le monde des entreprises le monde de la
politique et qu'on en ait pour ceux de
ce thriller évidemment politico
financier et j'ai été aussi directeur
général international du groupe
aérospatial aérospatiale ont élu j'ai
vendu des avions et des hélicoptères
donc non seulement j'ai été dans
l'administration mais en plus j'étais
acteur acteurs du monde de l'entreprise
alors votre dernier livre donc s'appelle
le pacte de corruption c'est donc un
brin paula on l'a dit mais il va
probablement plus loin que le bleu paula
et on y parle évidemment de ministre on
y parle de la dhr on y parle de la
coface de monde que vous connaissez bien
c'est très bien fait parce que l'on suit
à la fois une intrigue policière qui
nous qui nous piquent prend mais aussi
aux pénètre dans le monde des affaires
dont de la politique dont le monde des
relations
internationales et de la corruption est
ce que vous étiez en fonction vous avez
déjà l'impression de vivre dans un monde
un peu romanesque comme ça oui dans un
monde où il ya des personnages un peu
étonnant je prends un exemple j'ai bien
connu les personnes de mon âge est un
peu moins le connaissent de nogent
baptiste du mag oui appelé le
milliardaire rouge qui vendait de la
viande du beurre etc en union soviétique
qui avait une vision mondiale il y avait
aussi var sano le roi du sucre donc il
ya des personnages très surprenant est
tout à fait atypique très différent des
hauts fonctionnaires un peu coincé
convoi par ailleurs et là vous aviez des
gens de ce pays d'artiste et ses
commerces voilà ça ne les gens qui vous
le sucre de jacques rouffio exactement
tout à fait qu'ils connaîtront semaine
alors on voyage beaucoup dans votre de
l'île souvent grâce à faire d'ailleurs
parce que c'est des gens quand même
important
il va falloir peut-être qu'on précise
2,3 terme alors on parle par exemple de
grands contrats qu'est ce que c'est les
gros contrats alors les grands contrats
c'est les ventes de d'airbus de
centrales nucléaires du sinn clés en
main de millions de tonnes de céréales
c'est à dire des ventes d'un montant
très important qui sont général fait à
des pays qui n'ont pas trop de
ressources aux pays en développement
puisque la majorité des grands contrats
se font en chine en inde en malaisie en
amérique latine est donc un grand
contrat pour marcher pour pouvoir
aboutir a besoin de financement et de
garanties coface peut lui délivre au cas
par cas oui le ministère des finances et
le quai d'orsay alors justement on va
rentrer un petit peu dans le livre
certains hauts fonctionnaires notamment
le directeur de la drug direction dès
que dieu que des relations commerce
extérieur
sont inquiets d'une opération qui se
mène en équateur est plutôt de deux
opérations a essayé d'expliquer la
première c'est l'implantation d'une
usine sucrière
1 le problème c'est que c'est pour un
montant très élevé qui dépassent le
plafond du risque alors qu'est ce que
c'est le plafond des risques alors tout
d'abord ce qui a intrigué le haut
fonctionnaire qui regardaient le dossier
c'est que l'équateur qui voulait avoir
une usine sucrière et du beurre on verra
sa part n'a pas fait un appel d'offres
en général on fait un appel d'offres
pour voir qui sera le moins disant là
c'était une demande de gré à gré
directement la france on nous dit on
voudrait que la france
nos ventes une usine sucrière un gène ou
vendus hier alors déjà envie c'est d'y
assister c'est bizarre parce qu'il
cherche pas à avoir le meilleur prix et
en plus les usines sucrières est
implanté dans une région de l'équateur
où on peut pas mettre de canne à sucre
en
rappelant que c'est la clé du succès est
donc le premier réflexe du directeur de
l'adt reut c'est de voir si le pays est
solvable ou pas solvable et s'il ya un
plafond de risque financier qu'on peut
pas dépasser auquel cas il faut
éventuellement faire des taux d'intérêt
plus bas plus longs comme les crédits
classiques qu'on fait pour l'achat d'un
appartement ou d'un biens d'équipement
donc les grands contrats c'est toujours
sous réserve de l'accord du ministère
des finances et du quai d'orsay qui lui
regarde s'il ya pas des problèmes
humanitaires des problèmes d'enfants qui
travaillent ou je ne sais quoi donc
c'est examiner au cas par cas très
sérieusement alors il ya un deuxième
contre on peut raconter d'abord les deux
convaincus on vivra qui concerne halal à
un appel d'offres lancé par le ministère
des finances équatorien est toujours en
équateur pour 8000 tonnes de beurre et
là aussi ça paraît un peu suspect parce
que la cour spéciaux meurt en equateur
ça dépasse pas 7 mille tonnes et qu'elle
pourrait l'imiter alors là ça passe non
pas par là dreux enfin en partie mais
surtout par bruxelles parce que c'est
celle qui vend le beurre qui est stocké
à bruxelles et c'est en général du bird
français parce qu'il se trouve que c'est
du beurre origine france donc
il fallait avoir l'accord de bruxelles
pour le faire et bruxelles regarde sens
10 ans tient effectivement comment ça se
fait qu'ils ont demande autant
il faut sûrement ils ont sûrement les
capacités de stockage suffisante pour
que garder le beurre pendant un an sinon
tout le beurre va fondre donc il faut
regarder tout ça plus près et donc ce
qu'on soupçonne au fait c'est que en
réalité il y aura jamais 8000 tonnes de
beurre qui devrait être vendue à
l'équateur mais qu'on va en voir une
partie et puis qu'une autre partie sera
vendue à hirson comme sa source et ça
c'est ce qu'on appelle le carrousel
c'est une technique de vente classiques
malheureusement où on faisait semblant
de vendre un pays et le pays signé en
disant j'ai vendu et puis on le
revendait un autre
donc c'est une c'était une grande
spécialité de jean baptiste doumeng
faire deux fois ou trois fois laquelle
bute sur une vente c'est ça parce que ça
vaut tous les acteurs alors il faut
préciser qui en plus des aides
européennes qui fait qu'on peut vendre
moins cher mais que celui qui vend alors
c'est assez compliqué terre que à
l'époque c'était il ya 10 ans 15 ans le
le beurre européen était à un prix
européen qui est négocié chaque année
dans les négociations de la politique
agricole commune et puis le beurre sur
le marché mondial qui est beaucoup moins
cher donc on ne peut pas vendu beurre
européen sur le marché mondial un loto
donc on fait une aide spécifique qui
s'appelle une restitution
on va on va découvrir assez vite dans
libre avant pâle tout divulguer ah mais
non rien mais on peut parler de ce pacte
de corruption quand même entre deux
ministres alors déjà ce qui a surpris
à la fois
le ministère des finances français et
bruxelles c'est que ces deux opérations
sont faites par des entreprises qui sont
dans la circonscription du ministre des
finances quant aux illuminés des
finances et les fonctionnaires a dû
vider ces vies dans ses pas le miz des
finances même parce que on va voir il
est peut-être impliquer de nouveau
enfin il ya le ministre est impliqué et
puis il ya auprès du ministre quelqu'un
qui s'occupe des finances du ministre
est notamment qui s'occupe de l'argent
dont il a besoin pour se faire réélire
le but est donc quand un ministre
présente un dossier ou un dossier
présenté et que le ministre est impliqué
tout de suite on dit oulala est-ce que
c'est quelqu'un de sa circonscription
est-ce qu'il ya pas un risque de
pots-de-vin ou de corruption et là sur
les deux dossiers il ya techni sucre qui
s'occupe du sucre et à tradi l'est qui
s'occupe du lait qui sont deux personnes
très copains du ministre est dans sa
circonscription donc tout de suite à une
petite odeur âcre qui
peut-être qu'elle est peut-être quelques
jeux et donc on va y avoir une enquête
qui va être mené propos pour découvrir
s'il ya en effet ce pacte de corruption
et qui est confiée à douze
fonctionnaires alors il y en a qui est
l'ambassadeur en grèce pourquoi parce
qu'il a travaillé avant à bruxelles et
qu'il connaît bien tous ces mécanismes
et alors ils sp6 de ce genre de fraude
il est tombé sur une très belle carrière
d'ailleurs dans la carrière comme on dit
mais il n'est pas énarque il a cette
fois qu'on parle de lui il ya toujours
quelqu'un qui dit attention il n'est pas
énarque oui ça c'est un gros gros
défauts de notre système
notre système administratif de
considérer que les énarques des gens
bien et les autres c'est des gens qui
sont arrivés par la petite porte ce qui
est grotesque
oui je sais pas mais moi je trouve ça
grotesque à nos plus grands ambassadeurs
jean david levitte revenez n'était pas
énarque donc y en a plein les côtés de
sarkozy sarkozy absolument donc
discriminer les gens selon qu'ils ont
fait l'ena ou pas l'ena et stupide ce
qu'ils savent qu'ils peuvent toujours
toujours toujours dans les nominations
absolument j'ai toujours cette espèce de
discrimination qui est absurde parce que
ce qui compte c'est la qualité des gens
et non pas leur origine administrative
alors est le deuxième haut fonctionnaire
qui était chargé de cette enquête c'est
s'appelle denis bosque et il travaille à
la dreux et il est il préside la
commission des garanties c'est quoi la
commission d'exemptions de garantie
c'est celle qui donne la garantie du
crédit pour l'opération donc on ne peut
pas faire une opération en équateur en
l'occurrence sans avoir l'aval la
signature de la commission des garanties
donc c'est lui qui dit ou ce sera oui où
ce sera non voilà donc deux clans père
sont envoyés là bas pour se renseigner
pour savoir ce qui se passe est là
il se passe des tas de choses alors met
les bâtons dans les roues il n'arrive
pas à voir les gens qui voulaient voir
il ya des suspicions de ceci ou cela
mais c'est aussi un milieu assez vu il
fallait dans les ports équatorien on
n'est pas forcément reçus à bras ouverts
un les parties parce qu'il fallait dans
le port pour vérifier si le beurre qui
arrive est effectivement il ya la
quantité déversée où les lois et alors
là je peux vous dire que les les gens
qui s'occupent du port enfin les
les travailleurs n'accepte pas avec joie
l'arrivée de quelqu'un qui vient
vérifier ce qu'ils font donc ait eu de
bagarre même physique bling pour
halloween ce qui se trouve que ce ne
sont que le nonce a annoncé
l'ambassadeur et teint est un spécial
justement l'ambassadeur lui karaté n'a
pas fait l'ena c'est un excellent
ambassadeur qui vient de la france
d'outre-mer et qui a baroudé déjà en
afrique alors lui l'habitude de ce genre
de bagarre il a fait ça toute sa
carrière donc ça lui faisait pas peur
puisqu'on peut s'arrêter une seconde
justement sur les nappes puisque vous en
parliez vous parler de cette faune y ait
une sorte de doux confrérie forte entre
énarques vous connaissez tous 11e près
tous dans les chronos est absolument se
coller tout ya une confrérie comme entre
polytechnicien tellement entre
normaliens entre deux entre c'est tout
ça est ce que l on parle beaucoup de la
réforme de l'ena la suppression les nac
supprimer sans être supprimé totalement
dans la réforme et qu'est ce que vous en
pensez deux champions ne pense pas du
bien je pense que c'est un effet
d'annonce parce que quelques gilet jaune
ont dit à balai annoncé dire ouh là là
bas si on supprime les nasa peut-être
les calmer
parce que on a supprimé l'ena pour deux
raisons la première parce qu'elle ne
reflète pas la population il ya pas
beaucoup de fils d'ouvriers ou de fille
d'agriculteur il n'y a pas de raison de
refuser à normale sup est exactement
dans ce cas là on aurait dû supprimer
normale sup hec polytechnique l'école
centrale l'école des huit premiers et
deuxième argument ça fige les carrière
sa fiche de carrière parce qu'elle a été
un classement qui fait l'allemand
convaincante alors c'est pas ça le
défaut principal de l'ena que entre
parenthèses nous envient beaucoup de
pays qui ont créé dnas en se disant
tiens ça va être comme le bon système
français le gros défaut c'est que à la
sortie de l'ena le gamin de 23 24 ans
est envoyé pour inspecter les finances 2
d'une trésorerie ou g20 alors qu'ils
n'ont aucune expérience d'administration
et donc c'est un une incitation à
l'arrogance donc vous imaginez le jeune
macro qui arrive à 23 ans qu'elle était
qu'est ce que c'est que ça mais en fait
alors qu'il n'a jamais mis les pieds
dans l'administration sa mort est mal vu
par les autres fonctionnaires évidemment
donc l'idée simple c'est de dire on ne
peut entrer à l'inspection des finances
soit la cour des comptes autrichienne de
contrôle qu'au bout d'un certain nombre
d'années donc on au bout d'un certain
nombre d'années une fois qu'on sait
comment marie agasse radio parce que
sinon vous arriver comme ça vous dit
qu'est ce que c'est que ça donc c'est
c'est exaspérant pour autant des jeunes
peut-être plus tourner arrogance
exactement donc on aurait très bien pu
garer les un hacker une belle image
annonçait progressio dans la un autre
progression et un autre système de
classement et puis la sphère été réglé
mais là c'est un effet d'annonce bon je
veux pas faire de politique mais c'est
relativement évident qu'on fait ça pour
montrer qu'on fait aujourd'hui il ya
dire je vais à ranger le classement une
personne comprendre quand il s'agite
mais il dit je vais supprimer les naoui
à
elle été ouverte bref à part entré dans
le volet pénal est la réalité de la
réforme il ya une autre chose à dire que
vous dont vous parlez dans à propos de
l'ena c'est qui concerne l'autre
fonctionnaire pas le pas le pas le pas
l'ambassadeur m'élever le levier le
président de la commission des garanties
il a un rendez vous un moment avec un
pdg de pdg d'alstom qui lui dit mais
alors qu'est ce que vous allez faire
dis moi j'aimerais bien devenir
directeur de la drug évidemment parce
que vous avez occupé avec un poste très
important et puis après je prends tout
fleuret un signe agirait donc primé pour
tout fait ça veut dire à dire dans le
privé et le président d'alstom midi mais
non c'est pas comme ça qu'il faut faire
il sait maintenant qu'il faut partir
dans le privé vous êtes directeur dadre
vous n'êtes pas du tout sûr d'y arriver
on sait jamais
alors ça aussi il ya un diable ce
passage entre public et privé qui peut
choquer oui mais qui et je dirai pas
naturel mais qui est plutôt positif ce
qu'il faudrait c'est avoir des passages
dans les deux sens privé vers public
plus vite vers privé pour que les gens
mais qui traite des affaires économiques
au niveau général français et fait un
petit peu d'entreprises ce qui aura été
bien c'est que quelqu'un que le passage
soit plus facile entre le public et
privé c'est ce qui se passe aux etats
unis c'est ce qui se passe en angleterre
c'est ce qui se passe dans pas mal de
pays mais là effectivement attendre de
partir dans le privé après avoir été
directeur de la drug ça vous fait entrer
dans le privé à 50 ans étudiant en droit
alors oui ce truc j'ai été nommé très
jeune donc
par hasard au hasard et donc quand je
moi je suis partie dans le privé je suis
parti jeune ouais mais
dis donc elle gère ça c'est exactement
ça
il ya une autre chose qui est assez
qu'on remarque aussi dans le livre alors
on lalonde a dit yahya ce ministre des
finances français qui est soupçonné de
corruption on voit quand même et c'est
très intéressant si les rapports entre
le politique et la haute fonction
publique et on se dit quand même ils ont
quand même du pouvoir les politiques
c'est à dire que quand le directeur de
cabinet du premier ministre convoque de
hauts fonctionnaires
dans la vienne tartare ils ont du
pouvoir jusqu'à un certain point parce
que l'eau fonctionnaires a priori l'idée
d'un mobile egm bible donc un ministre
lui dit de faire quelque chose s'il veut
pas le faire et dit non
jusqu'au moment où c'est tellement
important qui se fait virer mais sinon
le haut fonctionnaire qui a un sens de
l'état et parfois supérieures aux
politiques qui fait ça pour faire
d'ailleurs il a un certain pouvoir qui
ait le pouvoir de s'opposer si quelque
chose me paraît contraire à la loi ou ou
à aux traditions ou est ce qui se fait
ailleurs dans le livre le directeur de
la droite
ils s'opposent et s'opposent ils s'y
opposent et il arrive est convoqué par
un conseiller du mythe des finances le
principal conseiller du ministre des
finances qui est libre au cas où vous
vous opposez mais là vous allez être
directement donc c'est à vous de choisir
exactement ça c'est des choses qui
peuvent arriver c'est vrai du faux pas
si vous êtes arrivé ça m'est arrivé
c'est brad ça peut arriver ça peut
arriver et donc oui on vous dit alors
pourquoi ça s'appelle le pacte de
corruption
c'est parce qu'au cours de leur enquête
nos deux camarades
s'aperçoivent grâce à des journalistes
d'investigation en équateur du coup qui
lui disent c'est bizarre quand même
parce que à une réunion de
l'internationale socialiste ya quelques
années votre ministre des finances
français et le nôtre équatoriens ont
copine et et ont signé un papier entre
dix ans s'il ya une affaire franco
équatorienne eh ben on se partage t on
se partage les ris pots-de-vin les
bénéfices donc
d'ailleurs le ministre des finances
équatorien qui a pas être dans les
villes et très décontractée avec sarah y
croit oui une certaine manière j'ai dit
à juste titre parce que quand on dit une
commission oui les gens se disant tiens
c'est bizarre
mais par vous patrick armes aux quand
vous achetez une voiture
et que vous allez vous assurez vous ont
demandé un courtier quelle est la
meilleure assurance le courrier c'est
quoi c'est une commission c'est à dire
un service rendu alors ce qui est
anormal dans les commissions c'est ce
qu'on appelle en termes techniques les
rétrocommissions c'est à dire une
commission versée en équateur qui
revient vers le ministre des finances
française sans cv ou inverse donc on
découvre ce pacte de corruption grâce à
ce journaliste d'investigation dans les
quotas compte ou non plus avec le
journaliste d'investigation du canard
enchaîné seulement voilà oui la presse
un jour un jour aurait même des
d'ailleurs on conseille notamment aux
alors ambassadeur d'aller voir ce
journalistes équatoriens qui est
inquiète un très bon jour lycée qui
connaît toutes les exams de morue du
pouvoir je reviens aux relations entre
le pouvoir politique et la haute
fonction publique
parce que souvent quand on entend les
témoignages d'anciens ministres
notamment ils disent vas là la seule
réponse qu'on a entendu quand on voulait
faire des réformes c'est non non c'est
le ministère c'est pas possible on
pourra pas dire qu'il ya une sorte ils
se plaignent d'une sorte d'inertie de la
haute fonction publique est ce que c'est
une inertie ou est ce qu'il vous faut
c'est une protection des principes de
l'administration française il ya un
petit peu des deux
mais le
l'exemple le plus typique c'est le
ministère du budget et la direction du
budget
quand j'étais jeune haut fonctionnaire
je sortais au ministère des finances
les directeurs sous nous ont reçus en
disant venez chez nous c'est ce qui est
le mieux et le directeur du budget me
dit les jeunes venez chez nous la
direction du budget c'est très important
levier pourquoi parce que notre job
c'est de dire non systématiquement à
tous à tous je suis moi je n'entre pas
dans un ministère pour dire non à tout
ça m'a un petit peu
surpris donc il ya chez les dépensiers
la tendance toujours internautes parce
que quand il ya quelque chose de nouveau
en général ça goûte donc que c'est la
préservation du budget en quelque sorte
vous seriez vous favorable à un spawn
système comand comme il existe macro
avait dire qu'ils étaient plutôt
favorables à celle de l'appareil mais
parce que c'est compliqué je pense en
france le système tenir changé au volet
haut fonctionnaire oui jusqu'à un
certain point parce que le spoil system
américain il est terrifiant parce que
tous les quatre ans sont changés toute
une série de gens dont les juges des
shérifs les directeurs les etc donc il
ya
ça ça tourne ça tourne ça tourne et
c'est très politisée donc il faut faire
ça de manière
parcimonieuse et bien calibrés je vais
au coeur de votre livre c'est à dire la
corruption
là évidemment c'est un cas très très
précis mais on se dit que dans une
société très mondialisé où il ya des
ventes des marchés il ya des chinois et
des coulisses entre escaut foba la
corruption c'est-à-dire le fait
d'attirer un peu le client lé pa de plus
en plus répandue et presque nécessaire
de lits non seulement elle est l ai
répondu mais elle est nécessaire parce
que dans toute une série de pays c'est
quelque chose de seculert ça fait des
centaines d'années que ces pays vivent
sur ce système qui est un système qui
considère comme normale et par exemple
dans certains pays africains où certains
pays du moyen-orient la corruption c'est
à dire se faire payer
permet de payer les fonctionnaires donc
c'est un élément presque budgétaire donc
c'est une tradition le dis jamais
c'est une tradition et donc quand on dit
à quelqu'un vous pouvez pas faire de la
corruption sur tel pays
vous savez le troisième mais les anglais
le font les autres voilà c'est tout le
monde le fait qu'en pense que c'est très
habituel comment faire un ou alors
lorsque là je n'y vais pas et puis c'est
le chômage n'est donc c'est un arbitrage
de compliquer davantage compliqué il
doit de plus beaucoup de temps
malheureusement alors je voulais parce
que vous êtes un des grands species du
commerce extérieur
on voit que c'est un des gros problèmes
à de la france est à peu près 80 9 88 et
95 milliards de déficit du commerce
extérieur
c'est une pente sur laquelle on est
depuis plusieurs années c'était pas vrai
dans les années 2000 on était plus tôt
écoutez c'est pas déficitaire ce moment
là coco ça se fait de 1990 à 2000 on
était excédentaire oui libre et et puis
à partir de 2000 ça s'est
progressivement alors pourquoi il ya
deux raisons la première c'est ce qu'on
appelle la désindustrialisation était de
moins en moins de viry mais c'est pas
une explication parce que l'italie et d
un trial is désindustrialisé aussi mais
excédentaire des enfants mais c'est que
depuis l'an 2000 en plusieurs étapes
notre système de soutien à l'exportation
dead a été progressivement démantelée
démanteler non pas volontairement mais
par exemple la dreux a été absorbée par
la direction du trésor pour faire des
économies or la dreux étaient en faveur
de l'aide à l'exportation et la
direction du trésor était hostile à
l'aide à l'exportation trésor qu'il en
vend ses trésors qui l'emporté bon donc
s'étaler us et oui en plus ensuite on a
fait du commerce extérieur un ministère
auprès du quai d'orsay près du quai
d'orsay et non pas auprès du ministère
des finances ce qui est stupide pourquoi
parce que le problème note comme un
extérieur fondamental c'est qu'on n'a
pas assez d'entreprises exportatrices or
il suffirait qu'on les trente mille
entreprises exportatrices de plus
exportant chacune 3 millions de roses
qui est pas grand chose et on supprime
notre déficit commercial pour ça il faut
que ce soit le ministère des finances
qui financent sur le cube parce que
c'est seul celui qui peut aller en
province vérifier quels sont les
exportateurs potentiels le quai d'orsay
lui voit les ambassadeurs s'installe sur
et donc il faudrait remettre oui dans le
vestiaire il ya au delà de l'industrie
des rations qui est évidemment un des
problèmes ya de fonctionnement qui fait
qui explique aussi ce déficit qu'elle
fonctionne pas soit une raison politique
pourrait pourrait améliorer c'est
seulement parce que dans les autres pays
c'est intéressant les autres pays
l'angleterre les etats-unis qui ont un
large déficit le pouvoir politique
soutient massivement l'exportation je
vous pose la question patrick carmouze
comment s'appelle notre ancien ministre
l'actuel ministre c'est
l'ancien musicaux à 6 ans est l'actuel
personnes le centre c'est plus parce que
ces derniers n'aient pas eu un moment
s'ils acceptaient jean-baptiste lemoyne
bons plans baptiste mois et bien d'un
franck riester mais qui s'occupe de son
entreprise mais il n'y a pas de deux
gros ténors comme il y en a eu autrefois
retombe à voile et vous avez dirigé
d'ailleurs
cabinet d'hamid du commerce et on a le
temps de
rêver quand même une dernière question
je vais vous poser vous avez sans doute
beaucoup d'anciens collègues qui sont
les vôtres votre roman est ce que
finalement il n'ya pas certain qu'ils
sont soulagés que ce soit plus un roman
que sous forme de roman ou un essai je
n'ai pas parlé avec eux pour une simple
raison que je suis un énarque un peu
atypique parce que j'ai très peu de
copains énarque parce que moi j'aime les
gens un peu marrant il ya d'ailleurs des
balkans
les énarques les laisse pas par volonté
mais c'est pas par des énarques je parle
du pouvoir politique est elle pas être
qu'ils sont à se soulager que ce soit
vraiment encore dit yasser roman qu'il
comprenne qui ploie ils voient ça avec
la hauteur qui convient merci beaucoup
françois david ça s'appelle donc le
pacte de corruption et c'est aux cauris
éditions temporis et c'est un oui voilà
un des rares ce thriller
politico-financier et qui nous fait
entrer dans un monde comme ça on pénètre
dans des deux mondes coup connais peu et
c'est absolument passionnant merci
beaucoup merci à vous
on
[Musique]